-Leslie, thank you so much
for being here.
-Thank you.
-We just had your daughter,
Maude Apatow,
on the show recently.
And, man, she's just crushing
it, crushing it, crushing it.
You know I love the family.
And Iris is great in
"The Bubble," too.
-Thank you.
-But you have great kids.
-Thank you!
-You've got to be very proud.
-I am so proud.
They're good girls.
-They really are.
They're just good people
and funny and great actors.
Oh, my gosh.
-I know.
You know, I don't know if
you feel like this,
but as a parent,
when you're given these
two beautiful little babies,
you don't want to, like,
ruin them with bad parenting.
-Of course.
-And so it's a lot of pressure
on us parents.
And, yeah, I feel like --
Looking at them now,
I feel like, "Okay, well,
maybe I didn't ruin them.
Maybe they're okay."
-You beyond did not.
You beyond did not.
You should be very, very proud.
They're awesome.
-They're, like,
good, kind-hearted people.
-Funny, funny.
-But we don't want to jinx it.
-No. No, no one's -- And that's
not even real wood at all,
so it doesn't matter
what you're doing.
Watch someone comes out
from underneath.
"Oh, hi."
Judd Apatow is your husband.
Very funny human being.
And you guys have been married
for 25 years?
-25 years in June.
-Is that right?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah.
-Wow.
-Isn't that crazy?
-It is crazy.
Do you celebrate 25?
-So, 25 -- Well, we are
planning on having party.
We got married
by ourselves in Hawaii --
just the two of us and
a banjo player and a minister.
And --
-Fun.
-It kind of was fun.
It was low-pressure.
And then we promised each other
that we would have a party
with friends and family at
like our five-year anniversary.
-Cool.
-We didn't.
-Oh.
-So then we said 10-year.
And then we forgot.
And then 15 and 20,
we didn't do it.
I think we're, like,
afraid that people
won't come to our party.
-What?
-I think that's, like -- Yeah.
-You guys, would you go?
[ Cheers and applause ]
The whole audience -- If you
invite the whole audience --
Yeah.
-Okay. That'd be fun.
-You have to have a party.
-You think?
-Yeah, you're
the most fun family.
-Okay.
-Yeah, you're great.
-I'm gonna work on it.
-Have a rager.
-We won't do it.
We're not gonna do it.
-Who care -- If no one shows up,
it's funnier.
-You think? Oh, really?
-Yes.
Wouldn't that be great
if no one showed up?
-That would be so bad.
-No, that's another story that
you come on the show
and talk to me about --
-Okay, okay.
-Yeah.
Here's a photo of you guys,
by the way,
on your wedding day,
you and Judd.
-Okay, so this -- Wait.
On our wedding day, Judd,
who I'd only known
with a beard --
-Me too.
-Yeah.
-I mean, I didn't date Judd
or anything, but yeah.
-He was a cute, like,
mountain-man-looking Judd.
And on our wedding day,
he decided to shave his beard
and showed up to our
wedding clean-shaven.
And it really scared me,
because I didn't know what he
looked like without it.
And my kids, when they were
little, he would, like,
suddenly shave his beard,
and they would start shaking and
crying and be like, "No!"
And, okay, so, this is --
He's so cute,
but, like, if you didn't know
what was under there --
Well, look.
Can you go close?
-Oh.
-But look at his teeth.
It's like...
-What do you mean?
He has good teeth.
I've also never really seen
a pose like this.
What's happening?
-Oh, and look at his --
-Like, are you falling?
Was he -- Did you know him
before this photo was taken?
Or did he grab you and go like,
"You're gorgeous,
I've got to marry you"?
-What is he doing?
-It's a very interesting pose.
I've never seen that
move before.
But he went for it.
-I feel like
we should be scared for me.
-Next time you guys are both
on the show together,
I want to re-create
the pose and the arm hold.
That's great.
I want to talk about
"The Bubble"
because it's very funny.
And it's about the pandemic and
actors and a big action movie.
But last time
you were on our show,
we talked about how
you love to roller-skate.
And then I see the movie,
and you're roller-skating
in the movie.
And I go -- It had to be you.
You put that in there, right?
-Well, I -- Yeah.
I was having so much fun
roller-skating,
and then I thought, "Oh, well,
my character should know how to
roller-skate."
-Of course.
-That would be fun.
And then -- Yeah.
So, it was super-fun.
But I did have the --
I was roller-skating
while we were shooting, and I --
It was, like, a windy day,
and I was doing, like, a turn.
And the wind,
like, whipped me around.
And I fell down on
my chin and cut my chin open.
And I had to be rushed
to the hospital.
There's blood everywhere.
And the doctor had to, like,
scrape rocks out of my inside
of a deep cut.
It was so gross.
And then, like,
they had to cauterize it,
which means burning it shut,
and then stitched it up.
-Wait. Who was your doctor?
Like, Pa Ingalls?
Corduroys.
Do you remember that episode?
-Yes.
[ Both laugh ]
-Dude, that was
a crazy episode, man.
Ma Ingalls --
It was that awful.
It was unbelievable.
I'll never forget that episode.
But you actually
brought a photo.
This is real.
There's you with your chin.
-Yes.
-It's very bloody.
It looks --
This is after they kind of
cleaned it up a little bit.
But, yeah,
it was very deep and gross.
-So, after this, you're like --
You kind of got scared
to roller-skate.
-So then I didn't roller-skate
again for a year
because I was so traumatized.
And then I thought, "Well,
I'm not going to let something
like that stop me from doing
something I love."
-That's right. See?
Confront your fears.
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Confront your fears" is
the theme of our show tonight.
-Okay, so,
I got back up on the horse.
And I made
you and The Roots a video.
-Yep, here's the video.
Here's Leslie Mann returning
to roller skating.
Roots, watch this.
-♪ You better come out with ♪
♪ Your hands up,
we got you surrounded ♪
♪ I'm in the back,
changing my outfit ♪
♪ He said "Blink,"
we gonna send the hounds in ♪
♪ I said, "Wait,
'cause here I come" ♪
♪ Here I come, here I come ♪
♪ You boys get ready,
'cause here I come ♪
♪ Here I come, here I come ♪
♪ He said, "Yeah, you better
come out with your hands up ♪
♪ We got you surrounded" ♪
-"I'm in the back --" Come on!
♪♪
The greatest!
I love you. Look at you.
-Right?
-The down move was the best one.
-I know.
-It's so cool.
-It's so weird
that I can do that.
-I'm so happy that you --
Thank you for shooting
that video for us.
-Oh, you're welcome.
-Now, we're here to talk about
the film "The Bubble," okay?
Written and directed by
your husband, Judd Apatow.
Can you set up what it's about?
-Sure, sure, yeah.
So, "The Bubble" is a hilarious,
laugh-out-loud Netflix comedy
which follows a group of
narcissistic actors
stuck inside a pandemic bubble
at a luxury hotel
attempting to complete a sequel
to an action franchise film
about flying dinosaurs called
"Cliff Beasts 6:
The Battle for Everest,
Memories of a Requiem."
-That sounds great,
but I just --
-Yeah.
-Were you just reading
the plot description or --
I mean, can --
-No. Oh, no, no, no.
No!
-Can you tell us who else --
Tell who else is in the film.
-Okay. So, it's a
star-studded cast that includes
David Duchovny...
Fred Armisen...
Keegan-Michael Key, Iris Apatow,
Karen Gillan, Pedro Pascal,
Maria Bakalova, and Leslie Mann
as Lauren Van Chance.
in the riotous romp --
-Introducing your...
-I would --
That's KNBC San Diego
calls "the lockdown comedy
we've all been waiting for."
We have a clip.
-No, no.
Now I say, "We have a clip."
That's -- I'm the one who
normally throws to the clip.
-Oh, okay.
-Yeah.
Here's Leslie Mann in
"The Bubble."
Take a look at this.
Oh, no.
That sounds like a baby crying
for its mama.
-Whoa!
-That ain't no baby!
-Oh, my God!
What are we going to do?!
-Oh!
-[ Screaming ]
-Somebody help him!
-Help him!
Hang in there!
-How does he fly?
He has no feathers.
-Well, somebody taught him
how to fly.
-Please stop!
It's okay! I got him!
-[ Screaming ]
-Aah!
-Yaah!
[ Screaming continues ]
-Alright. Cut.
-"The Bubble."
Leslie Mann, everybody!